you're very funny improviser you come up
with these extremely original characters
characters that I I'm always thinking to
myself I don't know how this guy came up
with this character
they're very original do you you did you
do one for us would you like me to do I
do uh I think they put something here
for you yeah I do a character by the
name of Dalton Wilcox who's a cowboy
poet you know about cowboy poetry and
I'll do him now but he has he suffers
from a certain delusion but we'll find
out all about that in a moment and just
wanna warn you once the Hat goes on I'm
not Andy Daly anything no I'm Dalton
Wilcox Dalton Wilcox cowboy cowboy poet
ladies and gentlemen welcome I'm Dalton
Wilcox the cowboy poet I've been
referred to by myself and sometimes
others as the poet laureate of the West
: that's true and today I'm here to I'd
like to tell you all about my book and
promote my book which is called you must
by your wife at least as much jewelry as
you buy your horse and other poems and
observations humorous and otherwise from
a life on the range there's a time limit
and you can find it at B Dalton
booksellers or wherever books is sold
and it's in the western section and the
poetry section cuz poetry would you like
to hear a repulsor I would very much
yeah there's a true work of cowboy
poetry from really the greatest
collector and chronicler of the wit
wisdom of the West who lives that's me
this one's called a dangerous life the
cowboys life is full of danger to risks
to his life he is never a stranger he
knows there's a chance his horse may
throw him he lives in fear that a storm
may blow him of all the ways the cowboy
can meet his end there are a few against
which he can defend his rifle can't
shoot the wind nor the fire it will not
work against vampires who stalked the
plains for cowboy blood and leave their
prey dead in the mud every shadow that
moves in the night gives the cowboy
vampire fright vampires vampires
vampires vampires with fangs as sharp as
new barbed wire they sneak up on Cowboys
sit behind them on their horse and ride
that way for miles of course
scanning the Cowboys neck to get a clean
bite and reduce his pallor to a ghostly
white
a vampire can look like anyone getting
killed by one would not be fun a smart
cowboy will carry a stake of wood and
bury it in the heart of anyone he thinks
he should some of these may turn out to
be regular men but better safe than
sorry then where were you I was wearing
a hat
you